Pride celebrations starting next month
the CDC is now warning of an mpox
Resurgence and is calling on men who
have sex with men and other people at
high risk to get vaccinated the agency
estimates that only around a quarter of
them have been fully vaccinated three
Studies released last week found that
the two-dose vaccine is 66 to 88 percent
effective at preventing an empox
infection with one dose that figure
drops to 36 to 75 percent empox is
spread primarily by skin to skin contact
common symptoms are rashes scabs and
flu-like symptoms it's rarely fatal
Michael Kelly co-owner of equal Pride
magazine was diagnosed with empox last
summer so loneliness was actually a
symptom mental health isolation is a
huge symptom but he says his symptoms
could have been a lot worse if he hadn't
received his first vaccine dose eight
days earlier